you've been saying you're influencing a
lot of [ __ ] which i agree with
uh you said that you influenced a lot of
people to wear vape i did but you
weren't the first
first don't matter whoever influenced me
oh i gotta give that to pharrell
and the clips when i met for when i met
pharrell this man gave me a pair of vape
shoes
i suppose i got a babe deal with my vape
collab bag i got vapes on in the crank
that video
i got babes on in the toy right there
that you holdin
right now i got baseball right now how i
ain't how i ain't
stop playing my first album i said i got
me some bad names and then went platinum
that's fast i ain't no foreign
100 everybody i knew i messed with for
real i messed with whoever y'all talking
about but
as far as me i really live this
this wasn't no brand commercial on tv
that you saw on the post then said we
gonna wear this because we know
this was in the hood in the trenches
where nobody knew what this was
and when i'm going to school when
bathing they're spending 600 700
on bathroom nights [ __ ] laughing at me
talking about
them fake air force ones you're spending
700
on the base bro everyone you know 25 000
a show before i got signed i had
i was getting i was on the internet
making 25 000 a day on sound click
before soundcloud soundclick was that
[ __ ] i was getting paid so i had money
to play with as a jits
selling beats on there yeah sound click
yeah i really were cashing out on base
and renee was really withdrawning on me
when i went to school like oh because
they didn't know
you need to get some joy that you need
to get some air for one don't fake for
one and we really was beefing like man
we really stood on that baby nape [ __ ]
right and now to see everybody rock it
like it's cool it's the normal thing it
went like that when we wasn't coming up
right it wasn't cool to it so yes i'm
gonna say i made [ __ ] wet fair enough
i mean i think that you definitely
introduce it to the whole younger
generation the hood
to my people yeah trenches you know what
i'm saying shout out to whoever they
said but come on not like they didn't do
it like soulja wig
mike crank that got over a billion views
well on youtube because i know they're
gonna correct me because they're gonna
look it up 580 million views on youtube
but a billion overall with everybody who
copy my [ __ ] together
i had bathing ape all throughout that
video whatever video whoever y'all
talking about ain't never reach half a
billion videos win whatever they whoa
okay so i reach more attention and reach
more eyes than y'all
they don't know y'all they don't know me
i don't care who own it
who promoted who got to deal with it i'm
the one that put the trenches on
it the streets matter more than anything
hey what happened with yums
because yum's was a wave everybody was
rocking the yum [ __ ]
and then it feel like it just kind of
went away first rapper with the emoji
yeah i mean that was the logo